to present the next award here is a man
of many faces only two of which are his
own he's had an interesting year in the
movies in the Princess Bride
he showed that the borscht belt once
extended into medieval Europe and in
throw mama from the Train he set the
actors guild back thirty years when he
led his director bang him in the head
with a frying pan number 10 scores okay
ladies and gentlemen mrs. Billy Crystal
thank you very much I wrote that before
the strike I'm here to give the award
for best sound as you knows in movies
Oh art art like me know in that it's
it's hard that well don't or people
don't mixer people who movie make it
quickly
Anton's or perhaps eyes the importance
on the movies I
I've always been in love with sound I
used to go to drive-in movies in New
York during the day because it was safer
and I used to listen to the sounds
there's strange sounds and all different
kinds of movies like in pirate movies
onboard ship you always hear this let's
do that all together shall we
or when marchello Mastriani is at a
sidewalk cafe the traffic is going by
you always hear the sound I hope the one
was seriously hurt hmm and why is it in
every Japanese science fiction movie
every actor sounds like this but
professor I have never seen the piece
like that
Tokyo may be lost I started
I started out
I started out imitating actors if you
have no talent here's how you can
imitate anybody in the world for
everybody across the world please do not
try this at home I am a professional but
watch how you can sound and look like
anybody for instance
Humphrey Bogart hey yo guy say hey put
that gun down Louie hey away from there
Louie
hey you guys say hey or the greatest
actor in the world Rin Tin Tin
anything on my face
the nominees for achievement in sound
are Empire of the Sun Robert Knutson
donned is Lyra mo John Boyd and Tony
door the last emperor bill Roe and Ivan
Chirac lethal weapon less fresh old
sticks Alexander Verne poor and Bill
Nelson Robocop Michael G thank you
michael j KO hot
carlos hilarious Aaron were shown and
Robert wall The Witches of Eastwick
Wayne Artman Tom Becker Tom Dahl and art
Rochester and the winner is Bill Rowland
Ivan Chirac for The Last Emperor
I think Billy said it all a little radio
mic here somewhere but I don't worry Sh
we'd like to thank Jeremy Thomas
Bernardo Bertolucci and everybody in the
Academy for making our dreams very
simply
come to reality thank you very very much
and before I wake up I agree with him
thank you
our third nominated film tells the story
of an Italian family in New York's
Little Italy the daughter falls in love
with the brother of her fiance discovers
her father entertaining his mistress her
mother picks up a man in a restaurant
and her grandfather takes his eight dogs
to the park to meet some friendly
poodles all while Dean Martin sings
that's amore it's called moonstruck